today's midterm elections feature the
most diverse group of candidates in US
history a record number of women people
from different ethnic backgrounds and
LGBTQ candidates are running for all
levels of government across the United
States think about that for a second
Paula Reid is in Arizona where two women
hope to make history tonight she joins
us from Tempe Arizona Paula good morning
good morning Gail we are standing in
front of a polling location where voters
have been lining up since before 5:00
a.m. but really the only thing we know
for certain about the Arizona elections
today is that the state will get its
first female senator as Democrat Kyrsten
Sinema and republican martha mcsalley
Duke it out for this coveted seat it's
not just here in Arizona across the
country there is a wave of diverse
candidates on the ballot fighting to be
a first I don't want anyone to elect me
because I'm a woman but we need to elect
because I'm better voters in Georgia
could make history by electing Stacey
Abrams as the nation's first black woman
to be governor of supporting people in a
marginalized community in Vermont
Christine how Quist could become the
first elected transgender governor
Minnesota at Michigan may pave the way
for the first Muslim women to Congress
with candidates Rasheeda Talib and Neil
Han Omar while these candidates are
Democrats Republicans may also break
ground in California Republican voters
could put the first Korean American
woman young Kim in Congress the number
of female congressional candidates has
increased by 44% since 2012 and women of
color have increased by 75% the face of
government could also change in other
ways roughly 1800 current and former
educators are vying for state seats and
an unprecedented 200 veterans are
running for Congress I've dedicated my
life to serving the country I love but
within the diverse field there is a
common thread
the stakes are high we can't afford to
get it wrong
unlike in the past I'm running for
Congress I've had enough I'm running for
Congress they're not trying to downplay
their femininity
I put criminals in prison during the day
and change diapers at night they're also
highlighting their unique strengths I
won't back down because progress is
undefeated
we just need to fight for it are you
ready many of those women are running
for office for the very first time it
was interesting to learn that nearly
half of the 50 states have never sent a
woman to the Senate and their five that
had never even said a representative was
a female to the House of Representatives
John Paula thank you